let's go next one shall
we who's next let's find
out it's me all right Jo come on get it
up Joey Joey all right get mine up uh
prepare
[Music]
yourselves what the
[__] all right here's mine what the [__]
is this do you have spaghetti ball and a
what the
[__] what the [__] are you on about bro
why do you think I was so
quiet spaghetti B a is the worst pasture
this is this this almost felt
foreshadowed with this with this [__]
timing I have a good reason for putting
spaghetti balla on my 3x3 okay all right
but nothing can be good enough Joey but
uh I have strawberry short cake skim uh
kangaroo sausages specifically kangaroo
uh Nat watermelon spaghetti bolognese
miso soup Sukiyaki and chicken
paos which one would you like to hear
first what the [__] strawberry short
I've never seen you never never eat a
strawberry shortcake from oh dude it's
the only cake I can eat why strawberry
cuz it's Strawberry Shortcake to me is
the perfect level of sweetness because
like every other type of cake I have is
either not sweet enough or it's way too
godamn sweet cuz I don't really eat a
lot of sweet things to begin with I
don't eat desserts um so but anytime
there's a strawberry short cake it
[__] slaps and I'll eat it every
single time but if we have if this like
fruit cakes or like chocolate cakes or
any other types of cakes I'm very
selective it's like a mood type thing
Strawberry Shortcake I can eat anytime
and I can just [__] pack that away
you crave this ship did you crave it Joe
yeah it's the only if if I see it in
like a restaurant menu or like if I see
like a cake place that has a strawberry
short cake I'll buy it it's the only
cake I crave every other type of cake
I'm just like eh whatever I'm not a cake
person I don't think I've ever craved a
cake if I think about it uh no me
neither yeah I'm trying to think if I've
ever craved a cake it's hard for me to
criticize this I think it's it's so it's
so weird
basic basic basic you were saying what
the [__] is that thing and you're saying
it's basic no I it's just it's just cake
with a bit strawberry in it yeah that's
why I like it it's fine it's just sponge
cake with it's very strawber I've will
say is that is it specifically the
Japanese Strawberry yes all right
because the thing about Japanese cakes
that I can like kind of like is that
it's very uh light fluffy flavor I think
nice but then they put like an ungodly
amount of cream on it love that I love
that and I love the fact that it's not
like the super
super I hate that why you don't give me
this joke of a food give me something
real give me something tangible like
what like more cake less cream like what
give an example what's it what's a cake
that's better than shry sh cake um [__]
what's well first of all if if you know
on the top on they always put tons of
cream on it I was just scrape it off you
know my problem with cakes you know my
problem with cakes and pretty much every
heavy desserts
it's like it's great it tastes great but
it takes up valuable stomach space of
like what I could be eating in like a
main course for like lunch that's what
I'm thinking that's what I'm thinking
it's like there is never a point that
like I've eaten [__] great cakes
before but it's always hampered my
enjoyment of the following lunch or
dinner and I [__] hate that well
that's why I think when it comes to
Strawberry Shortcakes I'd rather just
eat it as kind of like a snack type of
thing or like like kind of a dessert but
like way after the main meal okay you
know like like strawberry short cake to
me is kind of those things where like
you go out to dinner right at some
restaurant and then on the way home you
see like a strawberry shortcake slice
being sold and you take that home and
then you eat it at home type thing
that's what I like who the [__] started
birthday cakes I just I just hate them
birthday cakes yeah cuz it's like every
[__] birthday there's got to be a
cake and I'm like man it's just like I
don't like cakes much the worst part
about cakes what do you a birthday
terisu you know come we just do that
like okay do you know do you know the
worst part about cakes especially if you
buy whole one aside from like everything
it's it's like this is this is why I
don't raise don't ra cakes right you go
to a birthday party or a wedding or
something right they bring out the cakes
right and it's always this moment of how
many people want to eat the cake and
guaranteed half of the room are I don't
want eat the cake are just like eating
it out of obligation not because they
actually want the cake like craving the
cake but they always just like have a
few bites out of like obligation and
then there's always [__] leftovers
you have to eat it I'm like okay fine
can you come a small slice and they come
s wa what the [__] is this it's like
[__] like you tring to do a
trigonometry example here what the [__]
is this see and I think that's why Japan
is kind of nailed in that aspect of the
fact that they yeah obviously they sell
whole Cakes as well but a lot of cake
places in Japan they sell it as like
single actual like edible sized slices
the ones that you can just like kind of
pick up and eat oh my favorite cake
pound cake or banana banana bread to me
to me Pake good pound to me that like
defeats the point of the cake cuz the
cake is like symbolic of like some kind
of like celebration you know is it yeah
for me I really don't I'll never eat
cake out of a celebration outside of a
celebration yeah yeah yeah like to me
like the cake is symbolic and with Japan
setting it in like small slices I'm like
you have removed the one thing that I
will agree with about cakes which is
like the symbolic meaning of cakes cuz
yeah but Japan also made Colonel Sanders
Santa so you can't believe anything
they're doing they're just [__]
around like to me there was nothing with
like basic tradition there's nothing
more depressing than like seeing like
you know the candles on like a single
slice of cake you know what I mean who's
doing that you know you see you see it
sometimes especially like Japan is the
one place where you can actually do that
because they buy it with slices when
people bring me a cake for my birthday
and I'm like I'm not eating that I I
hate to break it to you I I just don't
like C that all right for your birthday
next year I'm bring it to yeah bring me
with the cand do that that's way better
that's like an a superior
cake can we just skip to the spag the
spag ball SP
ball I Joey why would you pick put on
here because this is a dish that my
grandma used to make me when I was
little and I have very very good fond
memories of making this with my grandma
Yeah but you sorry to bring a so story
into it would you still order this at a
restaurant Joey sometimes yeah this is
like actually I got a spag ball two days
ago this is the reason why Hershey is
popular cuz it was [__] in in the
trenches they used to eat it like listen
you're cled now am I saying am I saying
this am I saying this is the best pasta
dish no but I have the most Fondest
Memories of eting as he about your
memories tell me what you think's good
huh I I don't care a [__] about your
memories tell me what you think is the
best the best I think is the chicken
genov pesta that's good that's good good
with P that is easily the best P but
that's also [__] boring isn't it no
it's not boring yes it is no it's not
boring you know what's you know what's
boring spaghetti bolog that's [__]
boring you know what's not boring my
grav memories W spaghetti bow youor you
know's boring your grandma wow it was
her birthday
yesterday she have bolog no bet you
going cake as well Joey no she said she
was going to make spag ball when I got
home and I was very excited I would stay
back in Japan if I heard that I don't
want to go give me a real meal you guys
see this braing my 94y old grandma you
up McDonald you can grow up from spag
ball okay you grow up grow up Grandma
Joey never how dare you what are you
doing wake up wake up
she we deserve
better all right you should have said
you know you can you can still cook
bolock just use a different pasta that
that doesn't detract from you do better
does B work with other pastas yeah of
course it does it it definitely does you
think yeah with pen it's better with pen
that's true oh what's the butterfly ones
the butterfly yeah the bow tie on those
are pretty good I've had those as well
with B even with um [__] it's like the
most common one what the [__] it's like
spaghetti feels flattened I I like is it
fucini no Linguini is it Linguini
Linguini the uh terrible sorry Italians
I'm so sorry Italians the green is like
spaghetti with a little bit more bite I
think that's the bow tie one yeah what's
the what's the what's the no what's the
okay hold on we got to here Linguini is
not fetuccini is it fetuccini yeah
fetuccini oh yeah yeah yeah the flat one
f is like better spaghetti it's like
this is like way better than spaghetti
it because it absorbs and holds the
flavor there more there's more surface
area hold the flavor more yeah yeah flat
earthers are right when it comes to like
P because like there is there is like
the flatness just holds the flavor way
better fedini alfredo that's right that
makes sense now fet Alfredo right okay s
so better
sauce I think I like
Papi Papi past um what what what
next understandable Suman understandable
we don't have to talk about we've talked
about I changed your guys' mind by
taking to the place it's fine gentleman
handshake agreement handed take a
producer to Sigman as well yeah yeah
yeah I we took out I took my producer
and his girlfriend to the skim in place
and uh and he came back to me and he's
like I had dreams of that
place yes all right cool cool all right
kangaroo sausage this is another one
that I think is the best type of sausage
you could have Australians will agree
with me on this uh you can buy this at a
supermarket Kanger bangers as we call
them I would like to they're great next
time you guys are in Australia you
should try some I want to try these so I
can talk [__] in the correct way I'm
just speculating right now I just don't
believe it could taste better than
European sausage I think you'll like
them I think you'll like them a lot I
think I probably like I mean they look
great is that is that how an uh a
kangaroo sausage looks uh yeah I guess
it has the correct girth of a sausage
that I enjoy yeah no it's it's a proper
size it looks like a sausage you knowly
looks like a gone now gone Let's It come
on now that's you're being Panic
now that there there is a look of a
sausage and that looks like it will
taste good that looks like it has a
fantastic snap which is important part
of any sausage they do and also looks
like it has the right amount of girth
going on so you can cut it up and it
gets juiciness as well is on point
really I I like the sausages well you're
a fool of G so I don't know how to tell
you that uh the thicker sausages are
better I I don't know the ones where you
have to cut with a [__] knife and
fork not the ones where you can just
[__] shov generally thinner sausages
uh line up more to like the processed
kind of yeah hot dog style you can you
can definitely get like obviously like
obviously thick sausages are more
readily available uh when it comes to
you know proper sausages I just it's
okay it's it's kind of like too much
meat G can't handle the meat is that
what you're saying I think it just goes
back to like the wrapping the skin you
know it's it's just a that's the best
part of the sausage that's the best part
of the sausage sorry the skin is the
best part the when the skin snaps when
you bite into it that's the best part
yeah I'm I'm saying you get more of that
with like the thin sausages because
there's less meat in there do you no no
you don't unless you cook the [__] out
of this thing until it's like crispy on
the outside I know like whenever I've
gone to whenever whenever going to the
supermarket and I see like the million
different flavors of like the thick
sausages and sometimes I just see the
thin sausage and I'm like I thought I
wish there was more flavors for thein
saes in the the thicker ones right it
needs more pressure more power to
contain all that meat so it has a
greater snap when it's broken uh and I
and then the juice spurts out and you
get that flavor I'm very passionate
about sausages um he's a JoJo why
kangaroos though yeah kangaroos I I just
okay I don't buy it the like the thing I
like about kangaroo meat in general um
that I think I just prefer it over beef
I want to try it uh is that I think it's
pork sausages is the gold standard by
way pork is by far the best but I I
really I I put kangaroo sausages almost
on the same level as pork sausages is
like I think they have all of the same
qualities of a pork sausage but is a
little bit more tender than a beef
sausage if that makes sense so beef
sausages are awful though yeah beef
sausag is aren that great I feel like
some sausages Pork yeah pork is by far
the best but I think kangar is a very
very close second if not tied first